welcome to the man of recaps this is
dexter new blood remember dexter morgan
everyone's favorite friendly serial
killer he had a code to only kill other
killers so he was kind of a good guy at
the end of the original series dexter
was in a real bad place because he
blamed himself for the death of his
adopted sister deb dexter's young son
harrison was going to argentina with his
girlfriend at the time hannah but dexter
decided he ruins the lives of everyone
he cares about they're better off
without him so he drove his boat into a
hurricane and theoretically died but in
a brief epilogue somewhere cold we meet
so-called lumberjack dexter where he's
living a quiet lonely life of solitude
and grown a gross depression beard so
that's where dexter new blood starts off
ten years after the finale and indeed
he's living somewhere cold it's the
charming little town of iron lake in
upstate new york but dexter's not living
a life of lonely solitude anymore he's
back to his old ways of blending in by
being overly friendly and thankfully he
decided not to keep the beard he's going
by the name jim lindsey and he's not
actually a lumberjack he works at the
outdoor supply store remember dexter
morgan worked for the police as a csi
tech but jim lindsay's only connection
to law enforcement is that he's dating
the chief angela bishop and so dexter is
leading a happy quiet life here well as
happy as any life can be that involves
line dancing in the original series he
often talked to his imaginary friend his
ghost dad harry but his new imaginary
friend is his ghost sister deb who's
very proud of him for being 10 years
sober without you know murdering anyone
dexter still has his dark passenger but
every morning he goes for a hunt where
he specifically does not kill this white
buck to prove he doesn't need to anymore
but dexter's life is shaken up when
local douchebag matt caldwell comes back
to town and is generally an annoyance in
fact dexter learns his dark secret that
he killed five people when he
intentionally caused a boat crash so
technically he fits the code so now
dexter really wants to kill this guy to
remind himself that killing's bad he
gets up close and personal with this
beautiful white buck but oh someone
shoots it yes it's matt caldwell in a
gross violation of hunting safety dexter
was standing right there this crosses
the line for dexter he can't take it
anymore he covers his shed with plastic
duct tapes him to the table and it's
murder time again dexter's back but that
same night there's another huge shake-up
in dexter's life when his son harrison
tracks him down looking for the father
he thought was dead it's an awkward
family reunion harrison resents his
father for faking his death to get away
from him he had a reasonably happy life
with hannah in argentina until hannah
died of cancer then he was shipped back
to the states and put in foster care and
things were rough but he found the
secret letter dexter wrote hannah saying
he was alive just in case and now he
managed to track him here and the
trouble keeps on coming when the cops
are all over his property they want to
use his house as the base in the search
for matt caldwell so dexter's gotta race
to the crime scene and try to cover it
up shooting a white deer on native
american land is a pretty big crime so
he drops matt's glove by the highway so
it looks like he freaked out and fled
town and the search is called off until
matt's father kurt caldwell gets
involved and the wildlife camera showed
there was someone else nearby and the
small town csi guys randomly good at his
job and find signs of a struggle so now
the case attracts the attention of molly
park a pretty big true crime podcaster
so dexter's working overtime to keep
everyone off his scent but he catches a
break when the search is called off
because kurt caldwell says his son matt
called him he's fine it's what they all
thought at the beginning he killed the
buck and fled town but this is weird
because obviously he's lying what is
kurt caldwell hiding so now harrison is
adjusting to life in iron lake dexter's
girlfriend at first is mad about his
secret son but dexter's like hey i
promise no more secrets actually she has
a daughter harrison's age audrey who
introduces harrison to the wrestling
kids but turns out they're bullying this
dork and harrison stands up for him but
then that kid ends up stabbing harrison
apparently he invited him to be part of
the school shooting he was planning and
harrison tried to talk him out of it
then had to stab him in self-defense so
harrison's a hero for stopping a school
shooting but csi dexter knows that stab
wound doesn't work with harrison's story
dexter does what he does best some blood
spatter analysis and blood doesn't lie
harrison stabbed the other kid first
then stabbed himself to cover it up
dexter finds harrison's straight razor
the same kind that the trinity killer
used to kill harrison's mother rita and
dexter's worst fears have come true it
seems harrison has his own dark
passenger dexter tries to talk to his
son but harrison's still real mad at his
dad even matter now he's accusing him of
lying so they're in a big fight for most
of the season so harrison goes to a
party where he pops some random pills
and almost dies remember kids if you're
ever in this situation don't worry about
getting in trouble you've gotta call an
ambulance to save your friend's life
dexter is distraught but when he learns
there's been a bunch of overdoses lately
from some drug dealer lacing his pills
he's getting revenge it's time to murder
someone he tracks down this dealer and
goes with his old technique of cranking
him in the neck but just then the cops
found him too so dexter's gotta cover by
pretending to be just a normal angry
father and anyway the real problem is
the guy who's making the lace pills so
dexter tracks him down and it's finally
gonna be murder time but these small
town cops are weirdly good at their job
dexter's gotta cover again by making it
look like this guy odd on his own stuff
now back to the matt caldwell case
something doesn't sit right with chief
angela bishop so she goes down to new
york to find him in person but the matt
caldwell who was staying here with his
credit card is definitely not matt now
chief bishop also knows kirk caldwell's
hiding something while she's in the city
angela attends a law enforcement
conference and the keynote speaker is
none other than angel batista captain of
the miami homicide if you care about
batista's love life he does immediately
flirt with angela but he takes it back
when he remembers he's apparently
happily married anyway they get to
talking and for really no reason batista
brings up his old friend dexter morgan
who died in that hurricane and for
absolutely no reason also brings up he
had a son named harrison when she gets
back to town her daughter audrey also
randomly brings up that harrison while
he was super drugged mumbled something
about his father's real name not being
jim and this was enough for her to
google a picture of dexter morgan and oh
dexter's busted dexter tells mostly the
truth of how his wife and his sister
were both murdered and he just wanted a
fresh start but angela's like it's weird
these secrets keep coming out now molly
park is investigating kirk caldwell and
dexter records them so he knows what's
going on kurt leads molly to what is
clearly his secret murder cabin so
dexter makes up a flimsy excuse to bust
in here and save her life it's this
whole time there's been a side mystery
of runaway girls gone missing and chief
bishop's been especially interested
since her friend went missing when they
were teenagers and turns out it's kurt
caldwell who's got an endless supply of
young runaways coming to his truck stop
who he can pretend to be a nice guy and
offer him a cabin for a night but they
soon realize he's a serial killer who
likes to put on the oldiesong runaway
and let them try to escape before
shooting them now chief bishop realizes
that matt's fake phone call came right
before they searched the caves and
indeed she finds a dead body here the
body of her long-lost friend she calls
in dexter for his csi skills and indeed
he finds some of the killer's dna and of
course it points to kurt caldwell indeed
she was his first kill but he's able to
blame it on his father who had a long
history of abusing women at truck stops
and between father and son the dna is
inconclusive she's gotta let him go and
kurt now knows it was dexter who killed
his son matt because when dexter burned
the body turns out matt had titanium
screws in him from the boat accident and
titanium doesn't melt so to get revenge
cortez's goon kidnapped dexter but it
doesn't go well dexter kills this guy
and while harrison's been mad at his dad
kurt stepped in and befriended him so he
has him over for a nice little dinner
until he comes out in his murder outfit
like this ain't a joke kid start running
luckily dexter gets there just in time
to save him and it's like hey kid you're
not alone i have a dark passenger too
and father and son finally bond so
dexter tells harrison everything about
his dark passenger and harry's code to
only kill other killers so harrison's
like hey this sounds great you're making
the world a better place so let's bring
your son to work day as dexter goes to
kill kurt and harrison's ready to be a
part of it has dexter kills kurt
caldwell with him and dexter's really
excited he hopes this is the start of a
father and son serial killer vigilante
team but meanwhile dexter's girlfriend
chief angela bishop is starting to hear
about the seemingly unrelated slightly
suspicious things dexter's been up to
lately the drug dealer tells her about
how dexter needled him in the neck and
the dead drug maker has a needle mark
too and turns out there was a serial
killer who did this to all his victims
miami's own bay harbor butcher in fact
molly park did a whole episode on how
the real bay harbor butcher probably
wasn't james doakes but is still out
there somewhere so christmas is pretty
awkward when you think your boyfriend's
a serial killer in fact it was awkward
anyway because their teenage kids are
now dating each other and then it's the
most awkward this isn't role play you're
under arrest and she's built up quite a
case linking dexter to the bay harbor
butcher and she's been in contact with
angel batista who still has all the
files from when laguerta almost proved
dexter was the butcher so it's going to
be difficult for dexter to talk his way
out of this one for now he distracts her
by telling her about courage caldwell
and sending her off there she finds all
his victims including molly park who i
guess he managed to kill at some point
but now dexter's been caught and he
doesn't see a way out of this one it's
time for drastic action as he kills this
cop to escape so dexter morgan is on the
run he tells a son harrison change of
plans we leave it now but harrison's
like wait a sec how did you get out of
jail don't tell me you killed that cop
who was not a bad guy but my friend and
wrestling coach dexter's like yeah i
feel bad about it but rule number one of
the code is don't get caught but this is
too much for harrison who's like wait
dad i'm sorry but you've got to turn
yourself in for dexter that's not an
option he's going to go off on his own
but harrison's not letting him and he
repeats what dexter says to his victims
open your eyes and look at what you've
done and as dexter remembers all of the
innocent good people that have died
because of him he once again accepts
that he is a monster but he still
doesn't want to go to jail so comes up
with a new plan harrison you gotta kill
me i think he hopes that somehow killing
him will also remove harrison's own dark
passenger but if anything it's probably
just going to mess this kid up more but
in any case harrison does it and
harrison kills daxter that's where
dexter morgan's story comes to an end
bleeding out in the snow killed by his
own son just then chief bishop arrives
and also makes a weird decision she
gives harrison like 20 bucks and says
get on out of here kid you don't want to
be dragged into this and so as the feds
descend on iron lake where they found
the runaway killer and the bay harbor
butcher harrison drives off to start a
new life hopefully without any more
trauma and that's where dexter new blood
comes to an end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies and if you loved
this recap check out the join button and
support the channel as a member